edson a lei e é essa fatia a quando
pensar em fazer aqui a quando comecei a
trabalhar no processo do que seria a
minha apresentação em minha contribuição
para esta plataforma que o o detex o
anda é eu pensei em falar em várias
idéias poderosas tem tido ao longo dos
anos e com as quais algumas já teve a
oportunidade de implementar está
complicada e precisa falar em micro
empreendedorismo empreendedorismo
inclusivo que é um projeto que eu tenho
a psystar dispensei falará sobre como
superei um linfoma um cancro através de
terapias holísticas como o biomimetismo
fizemos pec que a meditação é pensei
falar sobre a carreira do desaparecido
para o país qual música que tanto me
perguntavam constantemente seja fui
fazendo uma série de uma lista do que eu
realmente queria falar e depois daremos
conta do que estava por atenção toda no
exterior é e no sucesso de coisas
exteriores e e e cria que esta prestação
força algo que viesse mas aqui dentro
que pudesse expor a fazer entender um
pouco mais da minha essência como pessoa
como paulo por pelos vistos a ideia que
há fora do paulo como artista ainda não
faz completa sentido quando entrei neste
processo fez um trabalho de agressão e
foi esta a imagem que me veio à cabeça
esta imagem porque angola sempre ganhou
contrário do que se pode perceber
algumas cabeças podem perceber até que
eles não tenham surgido em angola não
tenha vergonha machin de eu poder é ter
o ânimo e coragem se calhar a
inconsciência do falar com você
certamente sempre ganha porque a
vergonha tem sido algo que seguiu
durante muitos anos é uma das primeiras
memórias que eu tenho como como como um
criança tpi uma dois anos de idade fazer
uma uma viagem de luanda mas com os meus
avós meus pais e no aeroporto
vi uma mulher vestida é assim há uma
criança às costas com com trajes
africanos e bate para amarrado vá até
material rafaela vir a ser mais um
guerreiro aqui a falar em defender essa
mercadoria e aquela imagem foi de tal
forma forte pra mim que eu e desatei a
chorar baba e minha família não
conseguia perceber o porquê
depois do varão está a favor do meu pai
e continuar a chorar copiosamente
vou já aí está a contar a história da
senhora bastante depois do bar agosto
foi a minha vó a minha página quer a
educadora de infância comprou uma boneca
um pano e amarrou minhas costas estava
aqui tá difícil
amarrou minhas costas e eu fui obrigado
a fazer a viagem era com a boneca
escolas 7m company amarrado e foi assim
que fiz a viagem toda
durante a viagem só perguntaram o que eu
era mf
é que era uma menina porque deus tinham
vergonha de assumir que o menino
o vavá a boneca as costas
isso é muito complicado eu tenho como
livrar desta carga
hum
esse episódio é singular foi a relação
como dizia há pouco tempo a ela o show
foi um dos sinais que a minha família
não quis prestar a atenção enquanto eu
era pequeno porque obviamente a glória é
um pouco parecida comigo respondeu e
olhar pra vocês e foi é a força da onda
de uma criança que dentro dos parâmetros
sociais em que vivemos a culturais era
típica o menino com demasiado sensível
para o menino e até gostava de brincar
com bonecas é muita para vai muita
pegada do meu pai que voltava toda força
primeiro filho primeiro mede o primeiro
sobrinho tinha uma pressão enorme sobre
mim eu e era impossível é o impossível
não difícil apenas por também não tinham
essa preparação para conseguir perceber
como podiam lidar comigo um pouco tempo
um dia o meu pai depois de uma das casas
trouxe não uma carrada de brinquedos e
jogou no quintal e percebeu que não
tinha interesse nenhum é e brincar com
os carros nem com as bolas têm nada e
então pegou num papel e uma caneta e
ensinou a desempenhar
aqui é o atual contrário de todos os
outros
violentos é despertar em mim uma uma
necessidade imensa de criar e graças a
deus que isso aconteceu
a verdade é que esse é esse ato de
gentileza do meu bairro foi o último que
eu tenho comigo porque eu fui numa
viagem que nunca mais voltou
quem bate nisto é depois do assassinato
do meu pai no isso é eu fui enviado a
viver com os meus avós já maués
shyamalan considero malanjino é a minha
avó jovita sempre a escola não é com ela
porque a educadora de infância então
estava na escola e eu é graças a deus
tranquila primário e hidrantes m teve
uma boa prestação como aluno na escola
mas é sempre também é rasteira
responsabilidade de ter que ser o melhor
que podia ser tinha que ser doutor tinha
que ser alguém tinha que é ter o
suficiente para ajudar a minha família e
para os meus irmãos para é ter um um
estatuto social é a verdade é que apesar
de eu fazer todos os esforços para
conseguir esse tipo de estatuto social é
uma coisa que sempre fez me sentir a
fragilidade grande enorme mim é que é o
que também em piúma é e deixar de
expressar a minha carreira artística em
angola quer uma verdade minha que não
está preparado a aceitar porque nunca
tive ninguém com quem sentar na minha
família e com limite muito - não tem
essa de preparação e depois de tanta
porrada é de cal foi complicado que é
lindo mesmo
obrigado isso isto é muito mais difícil
do que parece é obrigado
já a all
olha clicado tamanho é de praxe desculpa
e agora estou a ami tem sido um processo
às vezes bastante rigoroso e eu nunca
tive a oportunidade de ser 5 80 gente e
muito menos em angola muito menos cinco
anos não é importante isso é
definitivamente um dos maiores
exercícios que alguma vez fiz e é por
isso também que a iniciativa de força
aqui
a tam em 2009 quando é superar dodô
informa é pra mim foi uma manifestação
física de problemas que eu tinha
psíquico giedo caio que eu tinha que não
conseguia chegar lá não é simplesmente
não conseguia não conseguia trabalhar e
não tive apoio é psiquiatras mundo como
muito fui ver uma uma saiki com uma vida
então agora sim com explicações sobre
alguma cura mas é inserir numa carreira
que até bem sucedida como como museu
como um cantor como ator em nova york
capital do mundo com os restos da volta
não é com os quais curiosamente a mãe
não conseguir identificar tanto tava
lino maia que não sabia o que ser gay
não é como é que o que eu fui primeiro
homossexual gay porque uma criança com
um ou dois anos tem a palavra
homossexual eu nem conheço
atividade sexual ainda nunca diz ex com
ninguém porque o texto termo e porque a
cultura que ainda que surgiu san
francisco movimento gay o que é isso
parece então também não estou aqui para
fazer nenhum tipo de direito
isso porque eu acho que tudo isso só
serve para discriminar ainda mais
acho que sim que o assunto bom para
refletir não é que já não sou criminoso
nunca fez mal a ninguém não tem o
registo criminal em lado nenhum tento
ser a melhor pessoa que eu posso ser
diariamente mas há países e nações como
um lugar do gana
a rússia em que pessoas acham queimadas
por serem 10 não é eu por ser gay possa
ser motivo de chacota alguém na rua ter
uma atitude necessária comigo só porque
sou gay não é um detectar o meu lado
humano né e quem vê isso né e até conta
que a gente não fica sempre só pelo pré
julgamento e esquecemos de de conhecer a
essência da pessoa então como eu tenho
essas perguntas todas e como também
tinha demasiado medo de entrar nesse
tipo de conversa com as pessoas é de
vender tudo o que tinha em nova york e
embarca numa viagem que acontece aqui
hoje
se ele voltará ao continente africano
conectarmos com gola perceber de que
maneira que eu podia contribuir para
tornar este reino um pouco mais
confortável pra mim e então foi quando
surgiu a ideia com a experiência das
minhas viagens pelo continentes e com
minha experiência como forma é
conhecendo várias comunidades em áfrica
é um aparelho que era necessário haver
uma diferente abordagem à tradicional
subir a idade e então decidi começar a
passar mais tempo nas comunidades e
poder contribuir com o que eu sabia nas
áreas formativas para dar ferramentas
essas pessoas o que chama meta do rei na
china que o método em alusão à minha
ruína
rihanna quer dizer conexão imaginativa e
este método tem exatamente a intenção de
falar com as pessoas muitas vezes quer
estimular a criatividade porque eu
acredito que crianças criativas tornou
os adultos capazes de de pensar em novas
soluções de quebrar o ciclo de pobreza
que até agora parece irreversível
estamos a falar em trabalhar em
comunidades com nível de escolaridade é
muito baixo em que o jovem são um país
demasiado cedo entregam salve-se outros
vícios como a droga o álcool também
demasiado cedo então como é que a
intenção é dar ferramentas mais 111
ensino que é quase
personalizado que a conhecer a cada uma
das pessoas e perceber qual é o talento
não terá essa pessoa é capacitar esse
talento e promover esse talento até com
o intuito de tornar comercial
rina reconexão imaginativa e da
imaginação porque a criatividade é tudo
né uma criança sem sonhos de uma criança
sem futuro
portanto é esta ideia é minha pequena
contra o meu pequeno contributo para
poder não só ajudar mais crianças que
sofreram atrocidades que eu sofri mas
também de ajudar a criar mais crianças
que não tenham que recuperar da sua
infância é o nation é uma fundação que
eu tô afundar aqui terá o nome da
fundação pais pela primeira vez
é é a minha contribuição angola é um
projeto que dá me imenso prazer é
apresentar aqui muito brevemente em que
é é uma união minha com artistas todas
para toda parte muitos os que
trabalharam comigo antes das diferentes
áreas de design a aas formativas a a os
testes a músico já todo o possível e
imaginário e então a idéia é trazer este
evento para cá e começar a viajar pelas
províncias pelas aldeias pelos meus ex e
tentar contribuir e
um e fazer com que isto seja é fazer
aquela diferença o o ser a mudança que
nós queremos veja é no mundo
obrigado
obrigado galera